moore
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en 94
j'étais à goma en république
démocratique du congo pour médecins sans
frontières il s'agissait de répondre à
une épidémie de choléra qui s'était
déclenchée dès l'arrivée des réfugiés
rwandais qui fuyaient le génocide ça
fait plus de 25 ans que je suis engagé
dans la lutte contre le choléra
et je peux vous dire que cette
expérience cette mission a été l'une des
plus dures pour moi encore aujourd'hui
on a eu en un mois vingt mille morts de
choléra
vingt mille morts je me souviens des
familles qu'ils déposaient leurs
cadavres le long des pistes parce
qu'elle ne pouvait pas creuser le sol de
goma c'est un sol volcanique très dur
les cadavres étaient ensuite ramasser
jetés dans des fosses communes
c'était terrible et on en a beaucoup
parlé à l'époque mais le choléra était à
goma avant cet épisode est resté après
cet épisode à goma et ailleurs en
république démocratique du congo
c'est un pays qui déclare entre 10000 et
30 mille cas chaque année
alors d'où vient ce choléra ici à genève
vous tourner le robinet dans votre
cuisine
vous avez de l'eau claire limpide pur
vous pouvez la boire tombera pas malade
parce que c'est de l'eau potable
ici c'est comme ça mais ailleurs
ailleurs dans le monde il y à deux
milliards d'individus qui n'ont pas
accès à l'eau potable de milliards de
gens qui boivent une eau qui est
contaminée par toutes sortes de choses
les déchets des substances toxiques des
excréments
ces gens n'ont pas le choix du boivent
cette eau parce qu'ils n'ont pas
d'autres et en buvant cette eau il
attrape toutes sortes de maladies dont
l'une particulièrement graves qui aient
le choléra
le choléra c'est une vieille maladie on
l'a éliminée d'europe et d'amérique du
nord
au 19ème siècle il ya 150 ans on
l'éliminé comment en construisant des
réseaux de distribution doré en les
séparant des réseaux d'élimination des
déchets des égouts en sorte que l'eau de
boisson ne soit pas contaminé par l'eau
des toilettes le choléra ça ce prêt
vient comme ça d'une manière très simple
comme beaucoup d'autres maladies
transmises par l'eau comme par exemple
la fièvre typhoïde ou la dysenterie
alors pourquoi est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
donc on n'arrive pas à se débarrasser de
ce fléau
on a toujours aujourd'hui dans le monde
dans plus de 40 pays
environ 3 millions de cas et 100000
morts de choléra chaque année tous ces
cas tous ces décès pourraient être
évités puisqu'elle est si simple à
prévenir pourquoi n'arrive-t-on pas
d'abord parce que le choléra ça survient
dans des zones assez difficile où il
n'est pas toujours simple d'intervenir
ça serait bien dans les camps de
réfugiés comme ici au sud de au sud
soudan
ça sera dans des bidonvilles ça survient
dans des pays en crise dans des zones de
guerre c'est pas un hasard si
aujourd'hui il ya une épidémie de
choléra women who ici au sud soudan ou
en somalie
ça veut dire que nos méthodes de
contrôle doivent pouvoir s'adapter à ce
type d'environnement l'autre chose c'est
que et ça ça me frappe toujours il ya
beaucoup d'attention au choléra qu'il ya
des grandes épidémies
ça vous avez vu vous même mais une fois
que l'épidémie est terminée
ça n'intéresse plus personne on sent un
peu tout seul mais le choléra disparaît
pas avec l'épidémie bien sûr il faut
après l'épidémie mettre en place des
méthodes de contrôle qui vont permettre
d'éviter son retour la fois d'après je
me souviens des camps de réfugiés
mozambique et au malawi c'était au début
des années 90 les corps avaient été
installées le long d'une rivière qui
s'appelle arrivée retirer qui débordait
chaque année avec la saison des pluies
et qui inondait le camp chaque année
chaque année on avait une épidémie de
choléra et avec msf on répondait à
l'épidémie et puis on préparait pour
l'épidémie suivante il y avait sûrement
mieux à faire que ça s'était bien c'est
pas suffisant
haïti également je travaille en haïti
j'ai retourne régulièrement
le choléra est arrivé en octobre 2010 en
haïti
on a beaucoup parlé choléra est toujours
en haïti et beaucoup il ya toujours 200
à 300 cas par semaine ce qui est
beaucoup pour un petit pays comme ça
pourquoi parce que beaucoup a été fait
pour améliorer l'accès à l'eau potable
pour améliorer l'accès aux toilettes
mais c'est pas suffisant pour stopper la
transmission
or on peut le faire la meilleure preuve
c'est ce qui s'est passé en amérique
latine dans les années 90
le choléra est arrivée au pérou en 91 je
travaillais en amazonie péruvienne
pour répondre à cette épidémie c'était
une épidémie énorme en 91 1 ou pérou il
ya eu 300 20004 choléra la situation de
sécurité étaient mauvaises le sentier
lumineux qui répondait la terreur dans
tout le pays
eh bien les autorités du pérou une fois
cet épisode aigu passé se sont très
fortement mobilisés ont développé des
programmes d'accès à l'eau d'accès aux
toilettes dans les bidonvilles qui
étaient les zones qui étaient les plus
touchées est très important des
programmes de communication de
mobilisation sociale pour faire changer
les comportements et en dix ans le pérou
comme tous les autres pays d'amérique
latine ont éliminé le choléra
un autre exemple au sénégal le sénégal
n'a plus de 4 choléra depuis six ou sept
ans donc c'est possible on peut agir et
éliminer ce fléau
alors comment faire concrètement il faut
tenir compte du fait tout d'abord que le
choléra pour se transmettre a besoin
d'une eau vraiment très sale très
contaminée il faut ingéré un million de
bactéries pour attraper la maladie
en corollaire ça veut dire que pour la
prévenir
y a pas besoin d'une eau absolument
parfaite et quand même des solutions
tout à fait basique de toilette ou
d'accès à l'eau potable
ici c'est en ouganda c'est un forage
avec une pompe à main ça suffit pour
prévenir le caller ce ne sont pas des
interventions très coûteuse deuxièmement
est liée à ce mode de transmission
choléra dans un pays même dans les pays
les plus pauvres c'est pas partout c'est
dans des zones très spécifique vraiment
les conditions d'hygiène sont très
mauvaises on appelle ça des hotspots
ils vont concentrer une grande majorité
des cas ils sont souvent à la source des
épidémies ou peut donc simplement en
ciblant ces petites zones c 4 à 8% la
population en afrique simplement en
ciblant ces zones arrivé à voir un très
gros impact et dans ces zones il faut
des mesures qui vont au delà de cette
réponse d'urgence purement sanitaire
la solution du choléra elle est dans le
secteur de l'eau de l'environnement de
l'assainissement de l'éducation de la
communication bien au delà du secteur
sanitaire
je travaille en ce moment avec sosie bar
par exemple sur un programme
d'élimination ce pays ami le programme
d'élimination sous l'autorité du vice
président pas du ministre de la santé
très bonne idée
et puis nous avons un vaccin contre le
choléra c'est un vaccin oral il est donc
facile à utiliser c'est un vaccin qui
est disponible en très grande quantité
qui est efficace qui permet de stopper
la transmission d'arrêter les épidémies
bien sûr c'est pas une solution à long
terme
on l'a bien comprise la solution à long
terme c'est l'accès à l'eau l'accès aux
toilettes
mais ce vaccin vous pouvez l'utiliser
partout même en zone de guerre cette
année nous avons vacciné un million de
personnes en somalie par exemple donc
pour terminer je voudrais dire que bien
sûr
aujourd'hui nous avons les moyens
d'éliminer le choléra y compris les
moyens financiers ce n'est pas un
problème technique
le choléra c'est une maladie très facile
à éliminer
même avec des moyens très simples
voyez ici pendant une épidémie récente
en tanzanie
comment les gens se sont adaptés et ont
bricolé un système de distribution d'eau
à 10 des cas et des bidons pour lequel
n'a même pas besoin touché bidon donc ça
évite une transmission mais le choléra
c'est aussi la maladie des inégalités
c'est aussi une maladie qui peut être
très politique et dans certains pays
assez difficile à gérer parce que
certains pays sont pas prêts à
reconnaître le problème et ça je crois
que ce serait une mauvaise idée
on n'a jamais réglé un problème en le
mettant sous le tapis ça serait il faut
au contraire s'engager beaucoup plus
reconnaître le problème donc mobiliser
les populations mobiliser les ressources
parce que le choléra c'est pas du tout
une fatalité
l'accès à l'eau potable et à des
toilettes c'est un droit humain
fondamental et je suis certain que si on
se mobilise tous ensemble on pourra en
finir avec le choléra
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]